- [Voiceover] Cotton candy.
Who knew sugar and air
could taste so sweet?
Well, a guy named James
Morrison, an amateur inventor
who's occupation and taste
buds didn't exactly align.
He was a dentist and during his lifetime,
James even became the President
of the Tennessee Dental Association.
- [Voiceover] Don't forget to floss.
- [Voiceover] But he was also
a confectionary enthusiast
with a passion for culinary advancement.
He paired with John C. Wharton,
an old friend and fellow confectioner.
Together the two designed and co-patented
what they called the
electronic candy machine.
The device rapidly spun and melted sugar
through small holes until it was fluffy
and nearly 70 percent air.
They called the new treat fairy floss.
They introduced their product
at the 1904 World's Fair,
selling it in small wooden
boxes for 25 cents each.
- [Voiceover] Thank you.
- [Voiceover] That's
about six dollars today.
Fairy floss was a huge success.
In six months, they
sold over 68,000 boxes,
grossing in today's money
around 440,000 dollars.
But despite the success of
the sugar spun business,
Morrison returned to his
day job as a dentist.
So next time the dentist tells you
you're eating too many sugary treats,
well blame him.
Awkward.